I know it's tough out there now guys but
I'm gonna put a smile on your face with
the funniest joke of all time okay guys
watch this huge does anyone have a full
version of that that was popping dude
all right everyone knows pickle rake
funniest joke of all time scientists
have proved it nine out of ten dentists
approves guess I'll just kill myself
where did he go doh I wonder where
pickle rig oh you've probably seen these
memes already but they're so funny okay
I have walked across the surface of the
Sun I have witnessed a man turned
himself into a pickle it was the
funniest I have will ever see isn't it
kind of sad that comedy has peaked for
humanity
should it be celebrated or is it cursed
top common vinson ipod drop i kid you
not i kid you not
he turns himself into I told you dog
a pink oh he's big direct funniest that
I ever saw a
I can't even remember why it was funny
to say it's such a strange joke where we
all just mass hysteria I'm not saying I
like picking more room or day whatever
is that it's infecting my mind
I can't escape it I just don't remember
the context why it was so fine just
remember it was open it's like the
Abraham Lincoln effect or whatever his
name was Nelson Mandela effect but
picker Rick we all knew picker Rick is
funny but I cannot for the love of God
tell you why I just know deep down in my
heart
akanda Israel could be real
if pickle Rick was real I've seen things
people wouldn't believe I watched a man
turned himself into a pickle that's
something to tell their grandkids come
on Greg
tell us the story about your culture why
there was this one time where this
horrible disease was spreading but we
all made it through thanks to pick a
rake a kid you not Isabel he turns
himself to pickle it's called pickle
Rick funniest I have ever seen
all right you get the point it's
different people I like this one I do
you think that a scientists turning
yourself into a pickle is funny I do and
I'm tired of pretending that it's not
what's there not to laugh about green
funny think of other things that are
funny and green yeah funny
I've ever seen be sure to watch it also
hear some heart medicine here you go
heart medicine I know people are doing
different treatments horrible ossified
combined with ice or toast it says but
still I'd have they tried showing them
pickle Reiki can I talk about that I'm
just gonna not joke about that look
Marimo he turned himself into a pickle
he's pickled Rick look Murray more
Murray Masson ifs pickle Drake Jesus
something to think about
it's Alvin do a pickle it's gonna pick a
wreck this is a cursed meme it makes me
feel things I don't want to feel Thank
You pickle
[Laughter]
that was cringe bro
sleepy my kid you not Fox he turned
himself into a pickle
he's called pick a brick I was pretty
good impression to DJ D I wrote you to
tell about design did he turn into
helping do the pickle and then he let
his Mikkel go to go to battle bit of
pickle and then his Morrison doctor
pausing and he took the poison into
Dawson and he turned into a pickle
saying thousand and they'll get the
serotonin into the batter Bonin and I go
oh oh oh Lin oh my mixtape is on
soundcloud please check it out
so basically alright so basically all
right I kid you mine
the guy took of me and he oh wait this
is another one his video of the guy from
Megamind dancing and he added the
caption to it
that says to me this music it was
hilarious you don't notice it was very
funny yeah you had to be there to
understand alright it's only half as
funny when I tell the joke pick a rake
finished I've ever seen get to seven
that's what I'm gonna rate it what do
you guys think top common Vince and Xbox
next May it's been a while since I've
done these there's a lot of memes to go
by
we've all heard the legend the sadness
the stories of the hero the era that
fell so far from grace it starts with a
Nintendo switch it starts with hey why
don't we go and watch the latest Marvel
film hey is it cool if I [ __ ] other guys
it goes those Street steps watch out let
this be a lesson to be learned couldn't
she just have waited for two months
until simp meme is over and this
wouldn't have happened all right
I'm 100% holding the woman accountable
for this one I dub sits in a sense I
think now's the time it's not funny to
laugh at things I don't like so many
people are missing the point this is the
beginning of the end for Ian I got it I
gotta say it's something sad about you
know come on
Ian's done classic works classic content
on YouTube that no one else will be able
to reciprocate reciprocate replicate yes
alright I were really gonna throw all of
that out the window for one little thing
I hate that about the internet you make
one mistake in your fanbase will just
turn against you
alright so what if I like look it's made
off all over again how they all fall one
by one I'm telling it starts with
Nintendo switch I did buy a Nintendo
switch yesterday and I'm not projecting
and speaking truth I have a meme saying
Ian it's a simple original and another
meme saying here's a [ __ ] daring are we
today
damn how is he possibly going to recover
from this no you can't let your
girlfriend send nudes haha printer go
money paint that ago do you think he
gets some of the cash do you think they
have like a split revenue set up I'm
just thinking about these things I don't
know I don't feel good if there's no
modern heroes and how am I supposed to
look up to huh
what if idubbbz just love his girlfriend
and wants to support her now what the
[ __ ] is that huh
Ethan what the [ __ ] is that sure but
she's still bad person I'm sure you know
her much better than he does your whole
career is based on criticizing people
you don't know my heroes they're all
dead
coming Messiah [ __ ] you think these
switch is gonna by themselves oh I get
it
Ian's invested and switched Nintendo's
switch stocks it all makes sense
he's gonna come out on top of this be
like Brooke guys I made like six billion
dollars here's a photo I never thought I
would see what is this it's so cringe
but it has three thousand retweets why
is this happening I don't like 2020 I
don't like it can we go back where's the
back you know we're never one jokes
about how things are bad these are bad
this is really bad this is really really
bad I'm not even gonna write this mean
because it makes me sad next name all
right something that makes me happy
funerals sorry funeral memes what let's
watch
[Music]
that bit died
[Music]
yeah I don't know what it is about
people going bye-bye it make me hot high
feeling high so high Oh God on the whole
bra
yeah guys when I die bury me like this
with pickle Rick that's all I ask
[Music]
oh my god she died she totally freaking
died dude holy moly slowly oh now I get
the funny
I see the pickle in the rape listen
we're all gonna die we're all gonna die
we might as well just die am i right
gamers might as well get it over with
[Music]
it's pretty good
I enjoyed this mean it makes me ha ha
it's funny I go pickle Rick
[Music]
you know with all the I think I realized
from the Apache episodes we've been
talking about the random chimp event
I've been so scared I've been literally
bunkered up in my home I haven't left
the house I've been pinging the pile in
the floor in the corner cuz I I don't I
didn't have to do that but regardless I
was scared of the random chimp event but
what I realized I was wrong what
happened was the random sympathetic a
pretty haha we got a good laugh I'll
give it a I'll give it a 6 point 9 XD no
no she's back she's back
[Music]
well she really did she really did belt
that Finn like that huh
I see well delphine right now where it's
spelled Elfie
all right money printer meme no you
can't just keep preventing collapse of
capitalist system you're delaying the
revolution no you can't just give big
banks 1.5 trillion when we need health
care and have student loads no you get
your skipping at all of global desire
these financial elites know you can't
just keep destroying the value of our
money haha money printing ha ha got'em
no you can't you need to go back to work
so we can increase quarter to GBP by 3
percent what about the stock market this
is government interference in free
market the labor theory of value is
communist propaganda RINO no get it
because boomer is gold by boomers go buy
these are times no you can't just hijack
my cell membrane and force me to copy
make copies of you protein bit there
good god these are so bad but still I
appreciate it healthcare please printer
broke sometimes that happens no you
can't just be happy with that reason the
world leads fricked we're doomed that
species life is hellish pizza no ha ha
serotonin brain juice I feel good that
look good serotonin be like brah
this means suck
have you guys watched the tiger
documentary this is one bit where one
one of his employees lost his frickin
arm from a tiger and his reaction is
this and we're gonna financially recover
we have to spending six times it's over
game words I'm never gonna finance it
recover your employee lost an arm she
might die it's funny because his life is
ruined
me paying 399 delivery fee plus tip
never gonna financially recover from
this me buying the Lawai shaker cup i
will financially recover for this it's a
great price so it's a chair you know
what I'll buy all of his merch
even though the economy is going down
the drain who knows maybe PDP merch
becomes the numeric currency once I
record the one this is out the door the
whole world right now never gonna fit
nation recover from this it's game over
Bros we tried this part was so insane
because Joe clearly puts up a pet on a
paramedics jacket before anything else I
thought about that too you should watch
it it's pretty interesting I haven't
finished it yet though have you guys
seen this video it's probably one of the
weirdest videos I've ever watched and
you watch the whole thing through and
it's just I don't understand what's
happening he's right that is a water
balloon I'm so proud of it yeah they are
I see so hey what I saw Hey
is that a warning my balloon I know
that's not what I think it is I don't
know boy I thought I was bad at classic
water I sold a he did not do what I
think he did water ice salt a the most
spit firing balls of all time how is
this like funny at all that's a great
question and I think you can ask that
about probably any meme that exists
today it's good to ask questions
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the sirens disscourn we hope you
guys are enjoying your online classes if
things get tough
just remember pick a Rick this is this
episode of meme review hope you guys
enjoyed smash like subscribe and they'll
see you guys in two days I need to play
with my Nintendo switch with my wife and
her boyfriend see you then
hey do you know what's big peepees do
they play PewDiePie's pixel ings of
course pixel ings is a creature
collecting game I'm the primary
shareholder over a Brazilian players
have downloaded and it's got a perfect
score it's safe to say it's the most
popular game of all time PewDiePie pixel
aims it's awesome
deal with it build with
[Music]
you